[Music]
news anchor brawl news oh hell yeah
so it about honey do you have boyfriend
honey do you have my friend to see she
said it exactly the red print to female
news anchors are in hot water after
getting into a vicious bar fight after
hours so they jump at a Jacuzzi I always
feel that like I always see how chummy
and [ __ ] a favor then I'm like [ __ ] you
guys I know you [ __ ] hate each other
and I'm so glad that it's finally
confirmed there we smile talked at each
other you look great hey you look
fantastic you thank you you having a
great day okay I'd have to disagree with
what I'm saying but back to you J let's
go to Joe with the weather this morning
I was always thinking about exactly that
there was this interview with who's that
Jesus UK guy he's like he's like a long
hair Jesus looking dude raspy um he's
like Richard no no no no he's he's young
brand Russell Brand I was thinking about
this Russell Brand interview with the
roomful of anchor people's and it was so
ridiculous because like the contrast
between those smug [ __ ] and in
him it was it was so different so you
see how [ __ ] weird they are because
he was just relaxed and talking like a
normal person and they're so [ __ ] out
there [ __ ] yeah and then like he
didn't get all uppity just because
everybody else was like that and I was
like that's dope yeah I liked watching
him in those environments we're like
I've seen him basically where he just
sexually harasses through the female
news anchors and it's great they love it
yeah yeah he's just hating on them all
that [ __ ] and they're like super like
you think Bobby Lee kiss try to there's
like a [ __ ] compilation of him trying
to kiss all the anchors that every time
he's like on it see that's where it
becomes sexual Ratner cuz its unwanted
whereas with Russell Brand they all
count they'll kind of liked it because
he's attractive yeah yeah yeah
interesting how that works huh you're
saying Bobby Lee's not attractive yeah I
think Bobby's attractive but
unfortunately he's close-minded women
I can't see past the look but the looks
of the fella though this takes place in
West Virginia from Charleston Charleston
so it's between a news anchor and a
weather anchor Oh hierarchies you know
that he's a meteorologist no I am a
meteorologist yeah so the news anchor
her name is Erika and the weather anchor
her name is Chelsea
so Erika went out for a night on the
town with her husband named Donald yeah
so then she was out with her husband
when then all of a sudden she ran into
Chelsea her co-worker because there on
the hot I wish I could see this I know
me too
they're on the same trophy's
broadcasting to it like the same
broadcast like they're in the same team
and so it would have been even funnier
if they were like rivals and [ __ ] like
ones from box and the other ones from
ABC know they're in the same quiet look
Sophie this is a news anchor this is a
weather anchor is she are they like diva
no one looks Asian she comes and breathe
they all look ambiguous that's the whole
thing she does look like an Asian she
does like I did say in looking like a
fighter sorry Asian absorb more words
that's a lookalike ago they want to
fight so bad oh yeah that was their body
language yeah
they wanna fight so bad chelsey [ __ ] you
was that after that no [ __ ] you first
though they did have some sort of issues
with each other during work time but
they treated me like [ __ ] this after
work there at a bar
Chelsea approaches Donald's which is
Erika's husband according to Donald
Chelsea started hitting on him but then
Donal was like I'm not interested in you
and then went back to stand next to
Erika and then he told Erica would
happen that's an Erica he staged he
confronted Chelsea or she confronted
tell you better [ __ ] tell me if the
girls hitting on you especially it was
the call you there yeah he better tell
love - I miss my dream is you're gonna
fight lose you're just laughing yeah oh
yeah I should just say tips nobody tell
you or not
Oh girls don't do that it was TIFF yeah
yeah just hitting on you right now I
don't wanna see Jill and Jill fight like
someone else out of our circle I don't
believe it
all right Ronda Rousey hit on me go get
her Geo she could she could she could at
that I respect him my father uh Bart's
leg oh really I'm so lucky she left a
trail of [ __ ] [ __ ] juice on his calf
so then Chelsea
so that Erica confronts Chelsea about
hitting on her yo you hating on my man
Chelsea and then Chelsea shoved Erica no
Buddha I wasn't what do you expect it's
good he's hitting on me I'm [ __ ] fine
I thought of know any guys feelings hurt
you're the one that talked he's giving
them jitter but I but they can't do it I
can only do it
all right fine so then Erica he just
looks like she sounds like that she does
sorry I'm sorry
so then they both fell over into the bar
area and then Erica said that her
eardrum had been busted in her left ear
which caused her to bleed and she also
got a large knot on the side of her head
which turned out to be a fracture she
has a skull fracture
from what yeah from what from them
getting into a brawl she's got some
ground weak eardrums she [ __ ] which I
yeah [ __ ] with the wrong chest look yeah
the vet I wonder if she took a shoe
[ __ ] some actor over the head with a
stiletto that [ __ ] that she will
probably create a little she bought a
cheap what they sapote that little nub
I love Tripoli to know those picture
pote days I knew you guys would love it
that was an Chelsea she got a summons
for a battery charge and now erica is in
the hospital
dan did a report on it that'll be dope
that's a little thing next on News at
9:00 I got very old Chelsea and somebody
looks like somebody picked a fight with
the raw news 11 anchor it's like [ __ ]
like that I [ __ ] love the fake
amazing I want to see that like bait
headline is right
our very own they never do it they don't
like to report on their own [ __ ] which
is too bad did anyone else their
competitors do it that'd be amazing
wouldn't leave I mean I know their
articles written I don't know about if
you don't want to see that they report
now back to you Chelsea and then she's
at the hospital with a [ __ ] cast in
the [ __ ] neck brace yeah [ __ ] you the
[ __ ] dress Chelsea goes back just
like I told that [ __ ] she still didn't
have like a news anchor for announcing
voice yeah I'm surprised that there's no
video in this day and age and there's no
video wait who hit on whose husband here
Tina her husband and she's on the has a
fractured skull in a broken eardrum even
though she's okay so she's not the one
that threw fists she was the one that
started pushing her so she got [ __ ] up
in cheese she's chill now where's the
husband's picture I don't know Donald
it's funny cuz it's such a role reversal
cuz usually like at the club girls that
get hit on is your guys and in the guys
who talk to my groom and talk to my girl
both ways in that environment I think
it's pretty 50/50 what do you mean oh
when other girls hit on other girls with
man like they'd get into it in this
thing with the best I'm so oblivious
though I just be like that's a friendly
person she bought me a drink you want to
go meet her she bought me drinks she
said she'd come in our apartment what's
up mean about that maybe she wants to
play games with all of us hell yeah oh
yeah I love playing games yeah we should
all hang out and then she's like and
then you're like okay so I talked to her
she says just me right now but I'm gonna
talk about we're gonna go there and I'm
gonna set it up and then you can come
with my friends I love this [ __ ] [ __ ]
sweet people like Joe I don't want to
invite everybody because you know we
just met and it might be kind of weird
Marga had that happen to him he got hit
on at a spa they were both naked
two guys uh him and a guy and then the
guy gets out of the tub right and he was
like yeah see you late or something like
that and he likes peck his ass out I
don't know I was gonna hit on I don't
really experience like too many getting
hit on my dude how did you remember that
situation enough to tell her that
because I've never because I never got
hit on before by a dude you're like
that's weird but I always hear these
gays stories that I go down at the gym
Joe bonds so I'm just there and I missed
by myself and then this guy comes in his
extra-friendly
and when I I know when I go on a hot tub
if I'm there to relax I'm just gonna be
there by myself and it's like a big
circle hot tub and so he could have sat
anywhere but he sat next to me and he
starts making conversation he's telling
me about how like how hard is it why it
was deep into your eyes I don't know but
he was like giving me a lot of extra
deets
I'm like this guy's really trying to
have a conversation he's like all my
flight was so hard and my neck is just
just so like whatever you wanted you to
rub it I'm just like there's a [ __ ]
lot of details and then later he walked
up and then when he came out of the
water and he held the handrail and it
looked back at me that's when I was like
Tina starts game he's trying to
tantalize you with his booty hole did
you look at his butt yeah I did I did
well how was it was the tantalizing no
it's kind of fat and wrinkly he was like
50 years old oh why is it that fifty
year old people don't understand how
they look I don't know maybe it would
have turn a gay guy on cuz he'll be into
gear at the beach yesterday okay we see
a guy walking and he's gotta be 60 years
old or something he's wearing tiny
little yellow shorts and he's walking
with his wife maybe you don't care thank
you it's about comfort at that point
yeah it's he's not wearing them for me
he's wearing them for him right yeah I
get it okay my bad cuz you know when you
go to like the new Beach or the people
who are the most comfortable or old
people but it's also only old people at
nude beaches only yeah cuz all the young
people are so self-conscious man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]